so the California Democratic state
convention happened over the weekend and
there were some interesting things that
happen including a lot including a lot
of booing of presidential candidates I
think you're gonna like this first of
all there's a guy running named John
Delaney he was a congressman in Maryland
from 2013 until this year he's polling
almost zero I think averaging yeah 0.5%
to be exact so he has no shot but he
showed up and he said medicare-for-all
might sound good but it's not a good
policy and it's not good politics and he
got booed so much that it actually got
awkward take a look but we need as
Democrats to build an economy that works
but it's got to be with smart policies
medicare-for-all may sound good but it's
actually not good policy nor is it good
politics I'm telling you
I'm telling you
a hundred
[Applause]
we we should have universal health care
[Applause]
we should have universal health care
seriously awkward moment because the
booing just wouldn't stop but I'm gonna
take a position on this that I know
people are going to miss here and get
angry with me about but if he had
tweaked what he said slightly it would
have actually been a really strong
statement with which I'd agree because
right now there is huge momentum over
Medicare for all but as I've said before
Medicare for all is just one way to get
universal coverage in health care to
everyone I've said before I'm a
supporter of Medicare for all over the
system we have and I'm a supporter of
Medicare for all over lots of other
ideas that have been presented including
you know the public option is part of
Obamacare or whatever else but there are
problems with Medicare Medicare is not
nearly a perfect system would I take it
over what we have of course a million
times over but remember that 80% of the
people who are on Medicare have
something else in addition to Medicare
because Medicare doesn't give them full
coverage some people are working while
on Medicare so they have some kind of
private employer connected insurance
some people who have Medicare are buying
additional coverage through various
supplement plans or they're poor enough
to get Medicaid in conjunction with
Medicare but the point is Medicare for
all isn't perfect and if delaney instead
came in and said listen instead of
saying Medicare for all is bad politics
and bad policy instead of saying my top
priority is getting health care to
everyone as soon as possible and I will
consider any system that gets us there
be it Medicare for all a massive
Medicaid expansion a nationalization
type system like in the UK a state-based
system that is similar to what Canada
has at the province level it doesn't
matter right that would actually be a
really great thing to hear from John
Delaney
because sometimes I agree the left gets
- they get blinders on with Medicare for
all when there are other options and
it's a perfectly reasonable debate to be
had to show up and say hey this is bad
policy and bad politics he's a fool he's
a fool and it's an idiotic way to
present it
but there is actually a good discussion
in there that we could have which is
Medicare's not perfect and there are
other countries that have different
types of systems which might be better
if implemented in the United States and
we should consider all of them we
shouldn't rule any of it out I've been
talking about that so huge mistake
strategic mistake by Delaney in a
boneheaded way really just putting his
foot in his mouth then in comes John
Hickenlooper at the same California
Democratic convention another Democrat
running with no support he's polling 0.3
percent Hickenlooper was the governor of
Colorado from 2013 until this year and
he said socialism is not the answer and
he got booed let's take a look at that
clip
if we want to beat Donald Trump and
achieve big-breasted goals socialism is
not the answer
[Applause]
one of the worst
in a quarter century
okay and the booing just went on from
there this is another dumb strategic
mistake I agree with Hickenlooper in
that for me socialism is not the answer
I want to sort of take control of the
capitalist system that we have and tweak
and tailor it in the way that the Nordic
countries and other northern European
countries have done Denmark Finland
whatever these are capitalist countries
that have said capitalism only goes so
far and we need to control it and rein
it in for the benefit of everybody in
our country to make sure people don't
get left behind so I agree with
Hickenlooper socialism is not the answer
but socialism is a non-starter right I
mean who's running on the socialization
of the means of production where workers
own every business and there's no more
private ownership of business I'm not
for that nobody's running on that right
why why is the guy even attacking
socialism at all
there's no candidates running on
socialist policies if it's an indirect
attack on Bernie okay but Bernie's
running on social democratic ideas like
what we see in countries like Denmark in
those other countries when Trump yelled
at his State of the Union speech we will
never be a socialist country and the
Republicans clapped and went crazy and
some Republicans did too I pointed out
this is idiotic red meat because there
is no serious risk that the United
States is going to become a socialist
country the Democratic Party has almost
no socialists in it it's a straw man
it's a complete and total straw man and
similarly when Hickenlooper shows up and
says socialism is not the answer
who's he talking to like okay there were
some people in the crowd who didn't like
it I would bet that even most of those
people who think that they're socialists
are actually Social Democrats I know
there are real socialists in the US a
lot of them don't even understand that
they're actually Social Democrats this
is yet another one of these dumb
strategic mistakes not that it matters
for Hickenlooper because the guy has
absolutely no shot talk about what
you're for rather than socialism is not
the answer because who's talking about
socialism I know that in some polls so
ilysm is less unfavorably seen than it
has been in a long time again many of
those people are talking about social
democracy but more importantly even if
socialism is less unpopular than it has
been in a long time which I agree it is
I mean it's clear from the polls that
that that's the case socialism has been
sort of reinvigorated in some sense
we're not fighting socialism the
Democratic primary is not a socialism
versus capitalism primary it's a how
regulated of a capitalist system are we
arguing that we should have how much of
the value created by capitalism do we
believe should be assigned to improving
society and the economy for everyone
regardless of their ability to pay in
their economic circumstances he's having
a debate with effectively nobody when it
comes to the content of the Democratic
Party dumb move dumb move by
Hickenlooper and Delaney but very little
risks since neither of them have a shot
am i misinterpreting this let me know
what you think make sure to give us a
like on Facebook at facebook.com slash
David Pakman show